[Music]
on this Wednesday night a very different
Canada day the partiers wearing their
maple leaf on their sleeve
the protesters pushing back what's going
on in the world little in Canada is a
travesty and the hope for change we're
in this kind of like paradigm shift
hundreds arrested in Hong Kong under a
new law fresh defiance as Beijing cracks
down on dissent America's escalating
crisis hospitals fill up as bars and
restaurants are forced to empty out
again and royal recognition through a
huge operation firm building high praise
from the palace to some Canadian
frontline workers
global national with Donna freezin
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us Kovach 19 has changed
just about every aspect of our lives and
Canada Day is no different the
traditional pomp and circumstance have
been put aside this year from coast to
coast to coast and its most noticeable
in the nation's capitol in any year but
2020 Parliament Hill would be the
centerpiece of the celebrations the
concerts and live entertainment even the
fireworks have moved online that's to
make sure there are no big crowds to
keep flattening the Cova 19 curve but as
Abigail Beeman reports some spontaneous
performances and protesters filled the
void looking much different than Canada
Day 2019 welcome to Canada Day in a
pandemic some adding a new accessory to
the traditional red and white a mask
Canada they love this country know I get
goosebumps and I have goosebumps and I
told my lovely wife we cannot say when
we have to go and do our civic to you
the we're trying to enjoy the day
despite of the pandemic this dance
troupe usually competes somewhere around
the globe on Canada Day it feels very
nice to be home for sure well because of
the current teen right we couldn't do
much but all our students get practicing
at home isolated so we decided to
finally to show that current teen
performance that we do at home it may be
a smaller audience but there's a
powerful message even though with the
coronavirus we're telling people that
there's always a positive things in the
world going on they still hope on
Parliament Hill no big show this year
but hundreds are using Canada Day to
protest there are a variety of different
groups here some with ties to the
far-right according to the Canadian anti
hate network their messages are
different many are anti Trudeau some
against Koba 19 restrictions
if taken dr. Chacon e'en and they're
causing more harm than good
whether it's all these council surgeries
or children being out of school we have
to hold our government accountable for
the actions are doing and that's the
reason we're here for our freedoms
usually Canada today brings people
across the country to our nation's
capital most of the people we found
today live in Ottawa
although these neighbors made a 2-hour
road trip from Montreal with precautions
my neighbor he sat diagonally behind me
and we had our math son in the car
sweating people in Ottawa were able to
partake in a common holiday tradition
cracking a cold one on a patio including
at the city's oldest bar it predates
Confederation I come here for a quart of
50 every single year for now well this
has been over 30 years
Dennis Conde is hosting for families
under four separate tents after this
this is a pre-party should get the
tradition out of the way and then go
start the new traditions rolling with
the pandemic punches on Canada's one
hundred and fifty third birthday
Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa there
were peaceful protests today demanding
Canada Day be canceled the new movement
is being led by indigenous rights groups
at a time when many are demanding an end
to racism as Geoff sample reports
protesters say they don't feel connected
to Canada's colonial history and the
injustice that had been carried out
Toronto's Kensington Market would
normally be packed for Canada Day but
this year looked much different and not
only because of the pandemic on the
street a group of artists painted the
words black lives matter it's a
different candidate a day for all of us
the national holiday comes in the midst
of a national reckoning after weeks of
mass protests demanding an end to racial
inequality we're in this kind of like
paradigm shift that hopefully we can see
further changes come out of this
systemic changes one change came in
Newfoundland and Labrador the province
will no longer recognize Discovery Day
the holiday criticized for celebrating
indigenous oppression yeah I always
found it kind of funny that the caller
to discover even though that when the
Europeans showed up there was a bunch of
people already here so serratus really I
find I mean I don't feel that it's like
hurting anybody like I love discovering
a to you Riley yes no sure does Canada
to us the indigenous former member of
the Prime Minister's Youth Council says
Canada Day should be marked with somber
reflection do you have an obligation to
you know really know this history to
honor this history in a way that you
know the people who did not benefit from
colonialism are asking you to the
hashtag cancel Canada Day was trending
online sparking a fierce debate crowds
carrying that message planned protests
across the country but some say they're
doing both protesting and celebrating
this 82 year old from st. John has spent
his life fighting for black rights and
working with youth he just received a
volunteer award from the Governor
General really growing up in the 40s and
50s
Thomas wasn't allowed in certain
restaurants or hotels the recent black
lives matter protest in his hometown
felt like a culmination of his life's
work after 82 years and this is the
first time I've seen some
many people come out in the community
and support
he says he's proud to be a Canadian at a
moment like this
Jeff sample Global News Toronto we have
some developing news tonight from the
world of hockey after weeks of
negotiations the NHL has reportedly
narrowed its picks for two hub cities
and both are in Canada according to
multiple sports networks Edmonton and
Toronto have been selected as the host
cities when the league returns to play
later this summer the deal still needs
to be finalized but TSN and others say
it's looking very likely that Western
Conference teams will go to Edmonton and
Eastern teams will go to Toronto reports
say a vote on the final plan could
happen later this week the NHL had been
considering a number of American cities
including Las Vegas but the league
reportedly shifted its attention north
because of the growing concerns over the
pandemic in the u.s. which is the
world's hotspot for weeks now case
numbers in that country had been spiking
in Arizona today authorities reported
nearly 4900 new cases that is by far the
biggest jump in daily cases in the state
since the start of the pandemic across
the u.s. more than 2.6 million people
have now been affected with Cova 19 and
with the July 4th holiday just around
the corner authorities fear is just
gonna get worse as Jackson prosecco
reports they're pleading with Americans
to celebrate at home across California
restaurants have been ordered to close
immediately joining shuttered bars and
beaches as cases surged 99 percent of
ICU beds are full the ICU we're doing
everything we can but we're not getting
there we're not saving our patients like
we want to in Arizona a
record-shattering number of new
infections while in Texas hospitals are
on the verge of being overwhelmed any
health care system in the world will be
pushed the thing with this kinda
exponential rising numbers in at least
30 states have created a dire situation
there are fears the worst days are yet
to come
I'm worried that hospitals are starting
to run out of beds
we are starting to run out of protective
equipment so I still think there's some
serious challenges ahead there's now a
stark divide in the u.s. between the
places where the virus is under control
and those where it's running rampant New
York New Jersey and Connecticut have
imposed a mandatory quarantine on
travelers from 16 states and we'll start
tracking the names of new arrivals would
like the Port Authority police working
with the airlines to get those names and
share them with the city and then our
tests and trace core can follow up at
every single one
New York has also taken indoor dining
off the menu it was supposed to resume
next week while Washington DC has told
residents to skip Independence Day
celebrations this weekend ask yourself
do you need to be there ask yourself can
you anticipate or know who all is going
to be around you there's still no
cohesive national strategy in the US but
late Wednesday President Donald Trump
changed his tune on a key public health
recommendation wearing a mask I'm all
for masks I think masks say that I would
wear if I were in a group of people and
I was close you would wear one I would I
would I have I mean people have seen me
wearing one Trump still doesn't support
a national masks mandate and still
hasn't worn one in public moves that
might convince skeptical Americans to
Don a face covering the fear is that
unless something drastic changes the
pandemic will become a runaway train 19
states are now pausing or scaling back
their reopening plans it may be too late
Robin Jackson prosecco in Washington
it's not just the u.s. recording major
increases in cases infection numbers are
going up right around the world as of
tonight more than ten point five million
people have contracted the virus and
more than 510 thousand people have died
in Brazil news outlets are reporting
more than 60,000 people have now died
and more than 1.4 million people have
been infected that makes Brazil the
world's hardest hit country after the
United States India is also struggling
to get the virus under control it's
reported a major spike in infections
more than 18,000 people have tested
positive and more than 500 people died
in just 24 hours some cities are
struggling to deal with the swelling
number of patients in Australia
authorities are taking a tough approach
to get a new outbreak under control
around 300,000 people living in suburbs
around Melbourne are now in lockdown
after a spike in cases anyone who breaks
the rules and leaves the lockdown zone
faces up to six months in jail
China's grip on Hong Kong just got
officially tighter as Beijing's
contentious national security law went
into effect pro-democracy groups accused
China of breaking its promise of keeping
Hong Kong independent a vow it made when
the British handed over the territory 23
years ago today as crystal commencing
reports the communist government may
want to silence those who don't believe
in its iron rule but they're not staying
quiet July 1st is a special day marking
the anniversary of Britain's handover of
Hong Kong to China but with a pomp and
ceremony civil unrest the new national
security law is now in effect giving
more powers to police to clamp down on
dissent this police tweet highlights
what authorities called arrest number 1
under the new rules the violation a man
with a Hong Kong independence flag when
they say day is night and dock is light
you just can argue because they are the
law but this is not the rule of law this
is not even rule by law this is rule by
decree
g7 nations including Canada and the UK
urged China not to impose its rules on
the territory for more than a year now
pro-democracy supporters have been
fighting what they see as China clawing
back freedoms so you hang on that cut
Hong Kong's executive Carrie Lam called
the new legislation the most important
development in the relationship between
Beijing and Hong Kong since the 1997
handover the UK doesn't see it that way
it violates Hong Kong's high degree of
autonomy and is in direct conflict with
Hong Kong Basic Law the laws also
threatens the freedoms and rights
protected by the joint declaration
Britain will now allow more than 300,000
Hong Kong citizens with British
passports a five-year stay hong kong has
one of the largest overseas populations
of canadians the government renewed its
safety warnings over the possibility of
violence
sherry wong says anyone critical the
chinese government is at risk their
families could be questioned by secret
police they could be put into detention
and i know that my work has already
endangered them it's unclear of people
charged under the security law will be
tried in hong kong or in mainland china
it was a proposed extradition law that
sparked mass protests to begin with
crystal commencing Global News London
China has sentenced a Canadian woman to
eight years in prison Sun Chien pleaded
guilty to x'd a two charges related to
being a member of the outlawed spiritual
movement felon gong former justice
minister Aaron Kotler who has helped
wences with son's case calls it an
unsettling show trial and that she was
unjustly sentenced to other Canadians
are languishing in China
Michael khovrakh and Michael stappord
were charged with espionage last month
after more than 500 days in detention
they were both arrested in December 2018
in what's widely seen as retaliation for
Canada's arrest of Huawei executive
mungyeong Jo toyota's no longer at the
top coming up the automaker that's jolt
the motor industry plus crashed on
camera when a car dealership becomes a
drive-through
some dramatic video has emerged of a
violent crash in Florida a surveillance
camera captured a car flying across
several lanes and then slamming into a
car dealership moments later a person
was seen leaving the scene the driver
was taken to hospital with injuries and
multiple vehicles were damaged one of
the world's biggest automakers is
recalling 2.2 million vehicles Volvo
says there are safety concerns with seat
belts the issue is with a steel cable
that connects to the front seat belts in
v60 v70 and xc60 models made between
2006 and 2011 passengers restrained but
can wear over time and possibly fail
Tesla is buzzing after blowing past
Toyota to become the world's most
valuable automaker the electric car
makers share price has more than doubled
since the start of the year the
company's market value is now two
hundred and seven billion dollars u.s.
vs. Toyota at 202 billion US Tesla has
had its ups and downs but in the 17
years since it was founded it has
managed to transform the motor industry
and move it away from combustion engines
final flag Falls still had the last
state to wipe its slate clean of a
contentious symbol
another symbol of racism and oppression
in the u.s. south has been removed the
city of Richmond Virginia ordered a
statue of Confederate general Stonewall
Jackson pulled from its pedestal it
stood there for more than a century
calls to remove monuments honoring
Confederate history have grown in the
wake of anti racism protests across the
u.s. with protesters pulling them down
themselves worldwide Confederate statues
monuments and the Confederate flag are
viewed as both symbols of Pride and hate
and have represented a sharp political
divide of a racial equality in America
what happened in Virginia today and with
the state flag of Mississippi earlier
this week our major historic milestones
to try and heal America's deep divide
Eric Swanson reports Mississippi has
flown this flag for more than a hundred
and twenty five years its Confederate
emblem protected by the state's white
majority of 36 to 48 passes so it was
shocking to see the Mississippi House
and Senate both vote overwhelmingly to
take it down once and for all for some
mostly whites the Confederate flag
represents southern pride that flag is
flown for so many years and it has a lot
of good meaning to it and very little
bad I think it needs to stay the same
but for blacks and many others it
promotes the darkest racist sentiments
in America I know firsthand what it
feels like to see a Confederate flag and
pretend it doesn't have a racist
violence violent or oppressive overtone
it screams hate and it hurts me to my
core the flag was the emblem of the
Confederate Army in the u.s. Civil War
it fought in part to keep slavery in
America slavery was abolished but
attitudes and policies of segregation
would persist wherever people protested
against civil rights this flag was
usually there five years ago a white
supremacist posed with the Confederate
flag then killed nine black parishioners
in a South Carolina Church finally South
Carolina
remove the Confederate flag from the
grounds of its Statehouse and now
Mississippi is the last to act the
killing of George Floyd seems to have
finally pushed Americans even white
Mississippians to recognize the systemic
racism that blacks have always faced in
America this entire state is screaming
for change the nation is watching they
want to know what we as a state stand
for from the toppling of romanticized
statues of Confederate generals to
removing racial stereotypes like Aunt
Jemima products the wave of change for
racial justice has been strikingly
public NASCAR racing no longer
associates itself with the flag leaving
it to its fans alone who've long viewed
it as part of their culture it's not a
racial thing it's a heritage thing but
that's what's so important about
Mississippi's decision it's taking down
a symbol of racial disharmony from the
last highest official level in any state
I know we could not continue to operate
for many Americans the Confederate flag
in Mississippi held a place of
prominence that it didn't deserve and
will no longer have Eric Sorensen Global
News up next the Brass show bowing out
on canada's birthday
[Music]
after 90 days trumpeter Andres Molnar is
ending his high-rise performances of the
national anthem in Toronto
vulnera musician from Hungary has played
o Canada twice a day on each end of the
23rd floor it started as a way to thank
frontline workers and earned high praise
from the residents in his building for a
group of health care workers in BC
Canada Day was a royal affair yes you
see even the Royals have tech troubles
on video calls the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge spoke with staff at Surrey
Memorial Hospital to learn about the
medical and mental health challenges on
the frontline of the pandemic and to
thank them for all of their efforts
coverage what did it just touch base and
say how proud we are of all of you
everyone on the front line who have led
the way very sterically very bravely and
application care you know right at the
top of the list and I've done a
fantastic job so well done to all of you
and I hope Katherine I could come and
visit you guys one day and say that to
you in person will and Kate mark the
occasion from home this year but in the
past they have enjoyed Canada Day
festivities up close nine years ago they
celebrated Canada's birthday as part of
their first official tour as royal
newlyweds and that is global national
for this Wednesday I'm Robin Gill
tonight the True North strong and free
has inspired one Canadian soldier in the
north
girdi funder of the Canadian Armed
Forces is wearing his national pride
while dancing Bhangra in Yukon thank you
for watching David akin will be here
tomorrow and I'll see you again this
weekend from all of us here global
national have a happy and safe Canada
Day good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]